il n'est pas encore question de logement
ni même du début des travaux la
problématique évoquée ce mardi soir en
salle du conseil municipal de
voisins-le-bretonneux portaient
principalement sur l'aménagement des
espaces publics voirie espaces verts ou
gestion des eaux pluviales
une première phase du projet urbain
exposé devant une quarantaine
d'habitants ce sont des premières
esquisses des premières études qui sont
faits par le par les cabinets qui ont
été choisis par l'agglomération et donc
ensuite effectivement va falloir rentrer
dans le détail de tous ces aménagements
c'est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
maintenant qu'ils ont vu le public une
première fois ils vont pouvoir se lancer
dans le bétail
l'autre sujet évoqué durant cette
réunion publique l'aménagement actuel du
carrefour entre la rd 36 et la venue de
la pyramide à proximité du terrain
bicross un carrefour modifié depuis
janvier pour anticiper le futur afflux
de véhicules et qui entraîne des
problèmes de sécurité pour les piétons
nous on est inquiet pour les enfants de
notre quartier qui vont au collège
champollion à pied et qui ont à
traverser ce ce carrefour et qui est
déjà dangereux j'habite juste de côté du
carrefour
je suis très intéressé par les
et parce qu'il va s'installer ici
l'organisation du carrefour
l'expérimentation je voulais savoir les
résultats que ça donnait à terme ce sont
500 nouveaux logements qui sont attendus
sur un terrain de 10 ha les premiers
travaux devraient débuter en 2019